we had jenna on this show i love your
daughter by the way she's so fun i kind
of feel like we are separated at birth
every time we hang out
um but she mentioned that the white
house was haunted
um did you ever experience that no we
never
i think barbara and jenna were the ones
that felt like there was that it was
haunted and
uh pretended like they heard voices and
it's probably just the secret service
talking down the hall in another room
that they heard but
but we didn't think it was haunted we
love living there it's a magnificent
house
and it has a magnificent art collection
uh which
was also fun to have the chance to live
with those
beautiful paintings no it's definitely a
beautiful
house i will say that i've been there a
few times and living there would have
been a little daunting for a kid i think
i think i would have been terrified okay
so i'm not sure if you know this
um but today is national no dirty dishes
day um so
who washes more dishes in your house i
think i know this answer you
or president you know the age i know
that yeah of course
i do of course i do yeah want more fun
stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure